rich
matt you've made it to the forge and
fire final
so far we've asked you to design and
produce a weapon of your own choosing
to claim the forged and fire crown you
must design and forge our mystery weapon
one of the most famous and revered
weapons from history
the japanese katana
the katana is the traditional weapon of
the samurai the noble class of warriors
in feudal japan since around 800 a.d the
katana was formed from hundreds of thin
layers of the purest steel available the
quicker draw of the sword was well
suited to combat where life versus death
depended on the weapon you carried into
battle over the centuries the katana has
taken on many mythical properties in
legend and culture from an ability to
slice through other swords to splitting
a hair and it is the sword of choice for
characters in mega hits like kill bill
and the walking dead good luck gentlemen
we'll see you in five days
my name is rich greenwood by day i work
on swimming pools and at night i'm a
bladesmith i'm absolutely amazed that i
made it this far at every stage of the
competition i thought this is it i'm
going home with five days i think i can
actually prove my worth
i've got no power hammers no presses
everything is by hand
my goal is to get the blade to where i
can quench it so what i'm doing here is
i'm breaking all the sharp edges because
you got any sharp edges you got a lot
better chance of cracking something
this is where it all happens it'll kill
me or it'll make me
here we go
about four seconds into the quench i
heard a loud tick
i knew that was it it was all over
several cracks along the tip
i just got the blade way too hot before
i quenched it and uh when you've got too
hot a blade and you throw it in cooler
water tends to crack
i'm not gonna say all is lost just yet
i'm gonna bust my ass and i'm gonna try
and get something made that i'm proud of
again
this is my final shot to stay in the
competition this blade doesn't survive
i'm out
getting ready
i'm quenching now
my name is matthew parkinson i've been a
blacksmith for 15 years
i'm going to go for a full hardened
blade so strong and so fine-grained it
should outperform anything else that
anybody can put on the table that's
ready for heat treating
i'm gonna slide my blade down there
about 600 degrees
i'm just gonna bring it up and let it
cool
i'm doing this for my son i'm doing this
so that he can be proud of me see what
daddy's doing he's sitting in the store
right now
nice i like the sword a lot
i'm still a little apprehensive about
what the judges are gonna be looking for
i'm just going to cut a couple water
balls to make sure the geometry is good
that was a successful test cut
this is a really good sword
to measure how your blades stand up
against flesh
doug will cut through these fish rich
yours is up let's put it to the test
nice
it will cut yes it will
it felt
good in the slice good but the recovery
was a little heavier but it still felt
like
it'll give me a close shave good job
okay matt you're up next are you ready
yep
it doesn't cut and i'm a little confused
by that i don't know why it didn't cut
it's got a very good feel to it it's
very light it's got a very nice bounce
to it and
it'll cut
now for the kill test
in this we have a ballistics dummy that
pretty much simulates the human form
organs and tissues
the katana traditionally has a razor
sharp edge
that allows me to find the gaps in
between the armor i'm gonna try that
with your blades to see how well it does
rich europe first
[Music]
[Music]
let's take a look at the damage
the thrust and the slice
went all the way into the internal
organs in here
and the kill shot went deep all the way
into the liver
i think on the kill test
this will kill
okay matt europe
yes
definitely through the laceration he's
disemboweled here
a nice
big puncture in here that definitely
will get the liver
i think it's past the keel test
you've both obviously brought deadly
implements of war here
but now
it's time to lock and load gentlemen
because for the strength test we're
leaving the forge we're heading to the
gun range
what
all right gentlemen
this is the final test for the forged
and fire championship it's the strength
test
your weapons will be tested on their
ability to split a bullet
your swords are going to be locked into
a vice
then we're going to fire a bullet at
your blade
all right matt you ready
break it
three
two
one
oh
engage
yes
well matt
your sword split a bullet
there's no damage on the edge at all
held up extremely well that is a real
true sign of your craftsmanship thanks
very well done
all right rich you're up next
when i look at him set the gun up and
get ready to shoot that blade
there's a little bit of doubt in the
back of my mind thinking it may not
survive this three
two
one engage
nice oh yes
this is great
wow
oh yeah nice
i like it the blade didn't even move
it splits the bullet
i couldn't have been happier there's no
mark on the blade at all held up
perfectly no chipping
everything looks great
thank you
congratulations gentlemen you should be
proud of the work that you've done
which only makes the judge's decision
that much harder we'll see you back at
the forge
matt rich
in just five days you have both forged
elegant and lethal japanese katanas
but in this competition there can only
be one winner of ten thousand dollars
matt
you are the forge to fire
champion congratulations
rich you did not make the cut i wish you
had done a little bit more finish work
you let the handle get a little bit
skinny and it was almost the same
proportions on each side so i know you
ran into a time constraint but it did
split a bullet and that's truly
something to be proud of i feel a little
disappointed but the better blade smith
wants
well matt congratulations you are the
forge and fire champion you're gonna
claim a ten thousand dollar check how do
you feel this is awesome
your blade is beautiful not only is it
beautiful but it's fast cut so cleanly
through the fish and on the ballistic
dummies that just disemboweled it for
the kill test great job blade aside i
was really impressed with your handle
set up symmetrically it was correct we
get good control good grip on it very
nicely done
this is such a rush i want to drive home
and kiss my son i'm the forge and fire
champion
you